In the depreciation video, we
saw that if a company had to
buy some equipment for its
factory, let's say at the
beginning of 2007, just based
on the cash that went out of
the door, there might have been
this temptation to say,
OK, in 2007, we had an
equipment expense.
EQ expense.
And they could have just
wrote, let's say that
equipment cost $50,000.
So they would have just put a
$50,000 expense right in 2007.
I write it as a negative number
just because I like to
remember it's an expense,
although normally people just
write it as a positive expense,
but I always like to
put a negative for an expense
to know that it's going to
subtract from your revenue.
So they would put that cash
expense there in 2007.
And then in future years, maybe
2008, 2009, 2010, they
would have no expense until
maybe they had to replace that
machine or buy a new one.
And we saw that that is one way
to account for things, but
it really doesn't reflect the
reality of the business.
The fact that this machine right
here that cost $50,000
is used for-- in this example,
in the depreciation video, it
was usable for two years.
Let's say in this example, it's
usable for four years.
So what they do is, instead of
just expensing the cost of the
machine, when the machine is
bought on the balance sheet at
the beginning of 2007, they
say, we now have an asset
called a machine.
I'll just call it
M for machine.
That's $50,000 at this point
right here, right when we
bought the machine.
Remember, balance sheets
are snapshots in time.
And then instead of having an
equipment expense, instead of
having that expense, they'll
have an equipment
depreciation expense.
And the difference here is
instead of saying that the
entire expense was that machine
in just the first
period, they're saying no,
we're using some of the
machine in that period.
And let's say we do a
straight-line depreciation,
which means we essentially
depreciate the asset evenly
over its lifespan.
So in this case, we're assuming
it's a four-year lifespan.
So let me draw that out.
So the asset should linearly
go to zero
over these four years.
So essentially, in the
first year, our
expense would be what?
It's $12,000.
If you divide $50,000
by 4, it's $12,500.
It would be minus $12,500 in
each year, depreciation
expense, and we would account
for it on the balance sheet.
Because remember, income
statements are just telling
you how do you get from one
balance sheet to another.
So expenses reduce the
value of your assets.
So, for example, in this one,
at the beginning of the
period, before the 2007
income statement, the
asset was worth $50,000.
We depreciated $12,500 from it,
so at this point in time,
the balance sheet as of the end
of 2007 or the beginning
of 2008, we're going to say
that our machine is now
$12,500 less, so $47,500.
And then at the end of 2008,
beginning of 2009, our balance
sheet under the assets, the
machine, if they gave us that
level of granularity, would
be $12,500 less than that.
So that's what? $37,500.
So then the machine
is $25,000.
And then another $12,500
on the books.
It'll say the machine
is worth $12,500.
And then at the end of
2010, it'll say the
machine is worth nothing.
And if we did our depreciation
schedule right, or if the
lifespan of this machine really
is four years, then
it's time to go buy another
machine and start doing this
all over again.
This is all a review of the
depreciation video.
Amortization is the exact same
thing, but it deals with
intangible assets.
What's an intangible?
It's something you can't see,
touch, feel, smell, eat.
Obviously , a machine you can't
do all of those things
to it, but you can at least
touch it and possibly smell
and taste it.
So an intangible asset, we can't
do any of that stuff to,
but it's the exact same idea.
For example, let's say we are
some type of widget company.
And let me write down
the years: 2007,
2008, 2009 and 2010.
And let's say that if we just
did it from a cash point of
view, let's say we had
to buy a patent in
order to make our widgets.
So we could have said, oh, we
have to buy a patent expense.
We had to buy a patent
from some
brilliant inventor someplace.
We could just say, oh,
you know what?
The patent cost $4,000.
So we could just put that there
even though the useful
life of the patent might
be four years.
And so it doesn't reflect the
fact that we still are using
that patent in these years, and
we just take the hit here.
So this income will look
unusually low, while these
will look unusually high.
It's not reflective of the fact
that you're using this
patent that has four
years left on it.
So instead of doing that, what
you do is, at the beginning of
the period you say, we have
acquired a patent, an asset,
that is worth $4,000, And then
every year over the life of
the patent, we'd amortize a
fourth of it since it has a
four-year life.
So it would be patent
amortization.
And there's all sorts of
intangible assets that you
might amortize.
And amortizing really just means
spreading out the cost
of this asset, just like
depreciation was spreading out
the cost of a physical asset.
So patent amortization would be
$1,000 in this year, $1,000
in this year, $1,000 in this
year, and $1,000 in this year.
And then our snapshot, or our
balance sheet at the end of
2007, will have on its
assets a patent
that's now worth $3,000.
And at the end of 2008,
it'll have a patent
that's now worth $2,000.
The end of 2009-- I think you
get the point-- you'll have a
patent worth $1,000.
And at the end of 2010, probably
because the patent is
now expired and anyone can go
out and produce whatever that
invention that was patented
without having the patent, we
then say that the patent
is worthless.
And a very relevant thing is if
you were a drug company and
you were buying the patent to
some pharmaceutical that had
four years left so that you
could have exclusive rights to
develop that drug. and at this
point, all of a sudden, now
anyone can develop the drug, so
that patent is worthless.
So the balance sheet is really
trying to capture what your
asset is worth at that
point in time.
At this point in time, your
patent is arguably only worth
$1,000, because you paid $4,000
for four years, and now
you only have a year left.
But that's all amortization
is.
Nothing fancy.
Really, in my mind, it's very
similar to depreciation.
Depreciation is tangible.
Amortization is intangible.
It could be patents, it
could be licenses.
It could be fees associated
with the financing.
Let's say you have some debt
that you took from a company,
and the debt is going to last
for 10 years, and you had to
pay a one-time lump-sum
to the bank.
Well, that one-time lump-sum fee
should probably be spread
over the life of the debt, so
you would amortize that
expense over its life.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.